[Música]
es la flor preferida de los franceses y
sin embargo tan solo una rusa de cada
cuatro lo recién el hexágono la mayoría
crece en África o América Latina
entonces la rosa francesa se juega la
carta del lujo en la costa azul durante
el verano crecen las rosas de la familia
mayón uno de los productores más
reconocido en el mundo aquí no sólo se
cultiva la Rosa se la crea mallas es El
heredero de una Dinastía que busca
constantemente imaginar la rosa inédita
y todo empieza con polen en una pequeña
caja aquí tenemos una pequeña variedad
que se llama sopetti una variedad que es
roja muy pequeña muy compacta
y aquí tenemos otra variedad de flor
Blanca muy grande
la idea sería hacer una variedad muy
compacta con grandes flores encima
aquí asisten a la fecundación de una
rosa que nos dará diferentes bebés rosas
Entonces esto es lo que me enseñó a ser
mi abuela Cuando era muy joven hasta los
10 años
seguridad directamente con los dedos
poniendo mucho polen una acción
ancestral que ya practicaba en 1850 su
bisabuelo jardinero en León donde los el
amor por la Rosa se transmite de
generación en generación la familia se
instaló en la costa azul y Durante los
años 50 esmaguel la famosa abuela de
Matías quien dirige la empresa y sigue
creando miles de variedades de rosa
Aquí está el padre
y aquí la madre de la variedad Sonia
que cuenta con todas las cualidades que
le pedíamos a una rosa
fue con la creación de la Rosa Peace La
rosa de la paz que la marca mello obtuvo
un reconocimiento mundial y el éxito
continuó Con la creación de rosas
originales asociadas a personalidades
ojo misch Schneider price Kelly o Paul
McCartney numerosas son las estrellas
que tuvieron el honor de elegir una rosa
para pusiera su nombre la creación nunca
para cada año la empresa invierte más de
un millón de euros en investigación y
desarrollo esta mañana el equipo
selecciona las nuevas variedades
en colores muy importante tiene que ser
un verdadero color este por ejemplo es
un rojo norteamericano típico y este es
un rojo europeo típico miramos también
el tamaño del capullo Cuanto más grande
el capullo de mejor calidad es el
producto si además hay olor entonces
salimos ganadores
todavía en la costa azul gas es la
capital mundial del perfume y la rosa
tiene un lugar particular en ello
[Música]
la nariz de la marca joke ha creado aquí
siendo de perfumes con un éxito mundial
siempre al principio con la rosa y sus
450 moléculas olorosas
es la piedra del albañil es decir que es
a partir de ahí que construimos todo
es posible encontrarle varias
combinaciones simpáticas por ejemplo con
madera con pachulí con notas de vainilla
notas más orientales para sus creaciones
usa un concentrado extremo de Rosa el
absolute en este pequeño frasco son
concentrados 10 kilos de pétalos para
obtener dicho elixir Aquí ocurre todo
las flores recolectadas en mayo son
ubicadas en este extractor para dejarlas
en infusión con solvente luego se sacan
los pétalos de Rosa tras 24 horas de
destilación aparece una capa de aroma
que se transforma en cera es la
sustancia pastosa para obtener el
absoluto hay que mezclar esta sustancia
pastosa en estado puro con alcohol
es un trabajo de filtración y luego de
concentración ser soluble en el alcohol
para que en el perfume el producto
perfectamente limpio
600 kilómetros más al norte en la ciudad
de Puma también se cultiva la rosa
La gallika una variedad quedada de la
Edad Media declinada en todas sus formas
hasta en los platos en la tienda de
carlado enú se les encuentra en mostaza
licor vinagre o bombones pero su
especialidad es el confitado de
[Música]
rosas es un tesoro se come bien con
foacra con
para fabricar su confitado Carla
recolectó y selecciono con cuidado 300
kilos de pétalos antes de congelarlos
Hace cuántos años que huele este perfume
27 años hace 27 años que huele la rosa
Sí en el buen sentido de la palabra
una receta transmitida de madre a hijo
los pétalos son mezclados en miel Que
también recolectan ellos hay que
encontrar el buen equilibrio para que no
quede muy azucarado
el equilibrio que sea agradable en la
boca y encontró ese equilibrio sí va a
decirnoslo
secreto secreto los pétalos y la miel
son calentados a la antigua con limón
agua y azúcar que no no se aburre de
trabajar la rosa creo que es un olor que
uno quiere siempre es universal ple
visitada por los franceses que la
prefieren a las orquídeas o los lirios
la rosa es la flor más vendida en
Francia con 22 millones de Ramos
elaborados cada año